back here on the riches and show one of
our favorite guests the match rule
himself with a new contract here on the
program how are you Matt I'm doing great
how are you I'm I'm feeling good but I
cannot imagine what it must feel like
for you what does this contract mean to
you Matt you know obviously very excited
you know one for myself family you know
it's it's just it's extremely special
but to you know to be a part of this
organization you know for the next six
years and you know hopefully beyond that
if I'm still going I heard you guys
talking about playing so you know I'd
love to be able to do that but you know
it's it's it's nice to know that there's
continuity here I'm excited about you
know how young our football team is
specifically on the defensive side of
the ball how many good pieces we have on
the offensive side of the ball great
coaching staff in front office you know
so to know that I'm going into battle
with those guys for the next six months
is great so I know the the usual answer
from somebody in a position like
yourself is you let your agents handle
that whole business but at what point
did you get personally involved in this
whole thing you know really towards the
end you know obviously you have
discussions with your agents kind of
early on and then just I really do I let
you know Tom Condon handle that he does
a great job and you know you know works
very professionally our front office is
amazing about it to you Thomas Dimitrov
and his staff do a great job with that
this is my third contract I've done with
the Falcons and each one really has gone
the same way where where they do all of
it and I get a call when it gets close
and let them know you know what my
thoughts are and that's you know that's
how it went down and and you know I
thought I thought the the deal itself on
both sides was handled really really
well so what would the kid pick third
overall in 2008 draft think of this deal
being the first quarterback with an
annual salary of 30 million a year what
would that kid think that
well I think he would like it I think I
think he would like that deal yeah yeah
it's it's amazing I really you know I
don't think about it all that much you
know about how long I've been here all
of look back too much but you know to
have come at certain times and how long
I've been a part of this organization a
lot of the really good things that we've
gone through during those 10 years it's
been you know it's been fun and I'm
proud of the way that things have gone
the last 10 years so let's talk about
the future here and how last year the
offense of the conversation about you
hooking up with Julio not as much in the
Reds owners as necessary the running
game didn't look the same with Kyle
Shanahan in San Francisco the Steve
Sarkisian coordinated offense not firing
on all cylinders what do you say to fans
concerned about a repeat of last year
this year Matt well you know I think
it's it's all doom and gloom I think we
did some good things authentically last
year too you know I think we led the
leading third downs which is huge that's
going to win to a lot of football games
I think you nailed it though the first
thing and it's not just connecting with
Julio in the red area it's across the
board all of us scoring touchdowns when
we get the opportunity that's the
biggest thing I think we had you know
however many chances we had in the red
area last year we didn't come away with
touchdowns from a percentage standpoint
and so that's got to be the point of
emphasis for us this year we moved the
ball pretty well 20 to 20 last year and
got the ball in position we came away
with too many field goals and if you're
going to want to be a great offense when
you get your chances to score touchdowns
you got in help and that's where we've
got to improve that's where we've got to
get better and that's certainly the
point of emphasis for for us during OTAs
and minicamp and in terms of connecting
with julio jones his whole social media
going dark scared a ton of people in
Atlanta Matt what have you connected
with him what was that all about is he
okay
we good he's yeah I've been able to kind
of talk to him you know what everybody
has has their own feelings on social
media
you know who who had made some comments
about that too and feeling that that's
not what define to him and you know has
the confidence to be able to do
something like that which is one of the
things I respect about him house I'm not
a huge social media guy I do it you know
enough but I get where he's coming from
that you know from that standpoint it
doesn't define who I am as well so I get
it you know I get how people could
overreact to it too you know that's
that's one thing I've noticed being a
quarterback in this league is that
sometimes people over reactive things it
happens occasionally but things are good
with him the one thing I know is we're
lucky to have him that's for sure
because he's he's absolutely the best
players in this league you know I think
he's gonna have a great year next year
so so his social media activity was more
of a stance on social media itself not
his relationship with the Falcons so
what you're saying well you'd have to
ask him about that you know I don't want
to put words in his mouth but that was
great understanding so you know that's I
don't want to get into speaking for him
but that was my understanding of it okay
and now that you've got a new weapon at
your disposal as well from the draft in
in Ridley how do you see that working
out this fall Matt uh I think it'll work
out really well you know I guess I'm you
know put should put on a maroon helmet
with a homicide with the two guys that
we've got two pretty good Bama guys on
the outside which is fun well I mean
that kind of leads me to the way that
you overheard the conversation in this
hour of the show starting Matt and it's
kind of weird to ask somebody who's just
signed a long-term deal as you have but
you are ten days shy of your 33rd
birthday
so when you see Big Ben say what he had
to say about Mason Rudolph what are your
thoughts as a starting quarterback when
you when you hear him say that he does
not know why they would choose somebody
that doesn't
helped the team win now Matt well you
know again I don't want to get into the
business of putting words in other
people's house but you know from a from
a from a competitive standpoint I you
know I understand the feeling of hey I
feel like I'm an established starter
League and you know when you are
drafting guys from a from the veteran
player perspective you're always saying
okay how can they impact this team now
so you know I understand that thinking
I'm you know from a certain standpoint
you know but you also have to trust in
the fact that the front offices of
reorganization have a plan for for all
things moving forward and you mentioned
trading Jimmy Garoppolo I heard a little
bit of that before I came on and how the
Patriots used that to advantage for
draft picks whatever that was at that
time so there's a lot of different
reasons people do certain things I will
say this I think Ben has some really
good years in front of I thought he
played extremely well last year and has
been one of the best quarterbacks in
this league for a long time so you know
I think he's still playing at a high
level and so you know I get it he wanted
to have guys maybe had other positions
that they could draft that you know they
could be more utilized on the field so
how important was veteran help for you
when you started in the league I was
really fortunate you know I was drafted
here to Atlanta I had a great backup my
first four years in Chris Redman a guy
that had bounced around a number of
different spots had played a little bit
but had been around some other guys too
and his mentorship his advice you know
that stuff was invaluable for me because
you just don't know what you don't know
when you come into the league there's so
many variables that are thrown at you
and he really helped he really helped me
sort through those things and and you
know determine what was important where
to spend our time and what wasn't
important what you cannot spend their
time on so ease the plan Matt Ryan right
now as we were chatting here in the day
that you put your Matt Ryan on the
contract
and uh ten days shy of turning 33 is the
plan to play in your 40s I would love to
you know and one of the things I'm
fortunate of is that my backup is older
than me right now oh yeah I got job ad
job who's older and more grizzled than
me I'm still taking his advice but yeah
I'd love to you know there's just
there's so many variables that can come
up whether it's health whether it's all
kinds of different things that can come
up throughout that you know through
throughout those years but you know I'm
doing everything I can to ensure that I
can play for as long as I can taking
care of my body the best that I can and
and really trying to stay in great shape
and it's trying to stay on top of my
skill set keeping my arm as fresh and as
good as it could possibly be you explore
all those avenues to try and be a great
player for as long as you can do it okay
so what is the rest of the summer look
like for you give me the Matt Ryan
playing outside of OTAs etc etc babies
right now they're two and a half months
now so the boys are two and a half
months and they're getting big and
strong and doing all that stuff and he's
been sleeping and it's fun it's fun to
be a part of that but trying to make
sure that they're sleeping through the
night by the time we get to to the
season yes you know I mean my 9 hours of
sleep
yeah there's no amount of money that can
probably guarantee that to happen but
you're getting in there with the diapers
though right your gear got to okay 100%
now I'm in there changing diapers doing
everything you can do I mean really it's
out of necessity with twins it's you've
got no choice but to dive right in and
do everything you can to help okay all
right what's crazier I mean have is
there a no-huddle situation with the
changing of the diapers Matt or how
crazy can that be it's a little bit
nutty isn't it
you never know what's gonna happen each
diaper change is a new experience take
it once typer change at a time and okay
Matt you know I've been interviewing you
since you came off the campus at at
Boston College and
and this has been it's just it's I'm
thrilled for you man I'm thrilled for
you so congratulations
I appreciate it rich it's always it's
always fun to be able to come out with
you and you've certainly been one of the
best to deal with throughout my career
so I really appreciate thanks and I know
I just found out there's at least seven
eight more years to go maybe a lot last
week I never know we'll see you never
know you never know take care of man all
right so you go that's Matt right the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience